JT's with us in Omaha Nebraska hi JT how
are you
you're David's Irish speak with you you
too sir what's up uh I'm actually oh
hello yeah hello hello all I heard was
actually and then you cut off hey there
yes sir I am are you there
okay yep sorry uh I'm on my way to put
in two with my two weeks after 17 years
of being with my boss Wow and uh we're a
small company and I only had a 50 cent
raisin in ten years and I've only been
able to tell my wife that thereby motor
for ten years only be able to tell her
that I had a raise one I took a
processor to take the position with
another company and I just wondered if
you had any advice on how to uh break it
to my boss because the employer-employee
relationships and board where you know
there's friendships and my family that's
kind of become one and I just don't know
how it's going to go yeah well it's just
going to be hard I mean you're you're
leaving people that you care about and
but um III would not say anything
negative I would just accent the
positive and say you know working here
has been like working with family and
that's been good and that's been bad and
I love you guys but honestly my income
wasn't changing here and so I had to go
the this other position came up and it's
a great income and I hope you're happy
for me and you know I'll certainly work
out the two-week notice if you'd like if
you prefer me not to I won't I will
honor and do whatever I'm supposed to do
with that um but I just want to thank
you for all the opportunity you've given
me and you tip your hat and you walk out
the door and it does no good to throw
stones back over your shoulder as you
leave okay it doesn't doing good at all
it leaves is it says more about you than
it does them I mean you've had 17 years
for them to give you a raise right so I
mean that 10 years yeah but I mean
you've been there 17 I'm sorry but yeah
you know you see what I'm saying it's
not so yeah this is past time to deal
with all this from an employer's
standpoint I'm sitting in that chair
most often and I mean I understand
sometimes people leave us because they
don't think they were paid or they leave
us because of X or because of Y and all
of that but the bottom line is they're
leaving and I'm not and so you know I
don't do a lot of I don't spend a lot of
time with folks that are leaving I'm not
mad at them it's not it's not because my
feelings are hurt or I'm thin-skinned
it's I'm looking forward and you're not
part of the forward picture and so you
know I just always appreciate it when
folks are just classy and say hey I
enjoyed my time here you guys are
awesome and feel like you know I'm being
called in another direction here and you
know sometimes we have folks to do that
we don't lose many that that way but
occasionally we do but I just recommend
you not spend any time talking about why
you're leaving and all the stuff that's
wrong with their company and all that
kind of stuff so no people do exit
interviews and they get into all that
stuff
I don't do exit interviews now some of
my HR team will sit down with people but
I don't I don't any patient for it you
know if you're exiting leave you know
that just exit that's what you there's
your interview you know because I'm not
leaving I'm going to be here doing this
and so you know and that's not to be
smart to you JT you've got a valid thing
here and you've made a good decision and
I don't think you're wrong with your
decision but I would just be kind and
thankful for the past and all the good
things in the past and we're moving on
to the next thing and you tip your hat
and your smile and I'm willing to stay
the - if you don't want me to stay the -
I completely understand that so hey man
thanks for the call hey guys Rachel
Cruise here hope you enjoyed that video
from the Dave Ramsey show if you want to
watch another great video check out my
video three things you should consider
renting right over here or click the
link in the description below